[Applaudissements]
au football les plaquages sont au coeur
du jeu les échanges peuvent aussi être
très dur dans le vestiaire où règne la
culture macho il aura fallu attendre
tout mail 21 cents ans après la création
de la première ligue américaine de
football pour qu'un premier joueur actif
affiche son homosexualité
je prends un moment dicale la cible pour
vous dire que je suis gay je veux le
faire depuis longtemps
là je me sens assez à l'aise pour le
révéler le joueur de ligne défensive dit
sortir de sa réserve pour les jeunes
sportifs homosexuels qui ont besoin de
savoir qu'ils ne sont pas seuls j'étais
soufflé en voyant la nouvelle dit david
testo le premier joueur de soccer
professionnel en amérique du nord
afficher son homosexualité en 2011
quand il jouait pour l'impact de
montréal
aucun homme est ouvertement gay dans les
équipe professionnelle de hockey de
basketball ou de baseball au football
un autre joueur avait affiché son
orientation sexuelle
juste avant d'être recruté par les
alouettes de montréal en 2015
sam est rapidement retourné aux états
unis mais il n'a plus joué dans la ligue
nationale de football qu'il a subitement
trouvé trop petit une mise à l'écart
peut être motivée par la discrimination
et pour ça c'est tout une histoire un
peu on peut passer que par les ja de la
nfl après qu'il ait annoncé
l'intimidation les représailles subies
par les athlètes qui affichent leur
homosexualité sont dissuasives
la peur de perdre son emploi aussi david
testo affirme l'avoir fait parce qu'il
se sentait en sécurité à montréal
la culture au québec ouverte et
accueillante dit il l'a encouragé à
s'affirmer à devenir qu'il est
aujourd'hui
il est vrai que les équipes
montréalaises de soccer et le football
au cassé la glace mais il reste beaucoup
à faire
la sortie de carl nassib patel faire
tomber les murs de résistance dans le
sport professionnel le justement il faut
aller se tiennent debout
jégo qui se tiennent debout que ça
devienne juste c'est que ça parce que
normal puisqu'il n'y a pas d'enjeu je
pense et ce que lui répondait le soin de
28 ans souhaite ici sortie publique ne
soit plus nécessaire que les athlètes
gais plus évolué normalement en
attendant carnassiers b devenu une
vedette instantanée son nombre d'abonnés
instagram a doublé en une nuit et son
chandail
le numéro 94 est devenu en 24 heures le
maillot de la nfl le plus vendu aux
états unis
ici se fit langlois radio-canada au real